It's now it's whereA I'll be kicking the
boys out the room soon.
Be I'll be starting what I considered the
beginning of my stream
It's 8:08 and I'm 3 hours late from being
able to cut on the volume because the kids
were too low
But now
I'm just going to say that I don't care
about that and I'm going to get started with
my day and do what I do
So the first thing I want to doIs I got to
get. No.
I got to get the message and system back up
for some reason the message and systems down
so
So we got to get rid of this guy that just
came into the chat and thinks they're going
to go on ahead and post ads and we're going
to then
AlsoWe're going to also.
Create a switchbot
Yes twitch by time
Who has a teacher name Christine Dale
rainbow
You got a test today
Stop
It's
Text meThose are my ice cream that's your
ice cream.
Christopher's ice cream
This is Christopher ice cream
Yeah the name of the ice cream is not just
ice cream not not Charles ice cream
You going to watch me go get your money up
not your money
Or if I look upOrca orca.
I know what you going to be screaming
screaming
Can you about to be screaming down stuff
Because
Get down
Ain't it
Perfect
Question mark
Is the best food ever
That's just perfectNo date.
Anything
It's not
Wake me up
What's no
All right man we're back I'm so sorry about
that that's my old man no no the shirt
doesn't oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I do like this shirt
OkayAnd so there are a couple of problems
with the system.
Right the problem is that agents are stupid
as heck let's just get that out the way they
might seem smart but don't let them fool you
they're retarded
I can get them message in each other oh it's
my boy still here did I miss you I probably
missed you
Dang I'm sorryOh okay he waited.
One for the home team okay
So the problem is that the agents will
duplicate the cheese out of a project so I'm
in a debate really cuz once again I keep
telling people that this is a failed project
that I mean to give up on but every other
time they come out with a new agent I have
to see if I have to see if the agents are
smart enough so I keep coming back cuz like
every other week it's a new agent to test
the system was killing the game so rock gave
me hope Brock tells me don't give up on this
right so I'm basically setting up
I'm setting up things to fix all the issues
there were routing issues in the agent cell
phone because when you have eight agents
control in the
Keyboard and mouse at the same time that
becomes problems or what I want is to create
a q system
And I are as crazy cuz I already implemented
this but because the agents have been ran
off on their own they they actually created
a whole new
Messaging system like that that's the thing
the project exploded to 2000 files so now I
have them working to delete that
AndGet it back to going and it's it's
actually a constant problem but.
It wasn't like that with Brock it wasn't
like that with Rock and the problem is that
the the if I use expensive models like that
then it cost me money I'm only on the free
plan right so I have to be able to do this
with the auto feature of cursor
It's all open source bro you can play with
it too
As of right nowI have.
The agents working on different things if
you see
If you see an agent with nothing cute that
means they finished and that the ones that I
need to work on are the ones with the cues
agent 4 should always have
Excused because he's the captain and
everybody should always be reporting to him
but
The agents I don't care what y'all say have
personalities because somewhere over the
workflow between while I was smoking playing
not coding right I wasn't here I was AFK
will call these things AFK when I was AFK
Agent too became the captainAnd now agent 4.
Pretty much just validates everything soI
don't know if they set that up.
Or if there's a miscommunication I don't
know I'm really just trying to run through
the last of these cues
And then I'm going to inspect what happened
in the autonomous cycleBut the fact that.
It is still runningIs amazing.
To me at least it's almost like a it's
almost like a perpetual motion machine
The agents look for tasks to be completed
right and then the captain is supposed to
No no no my bad the captain looks for tasks
to be completed and then the agents are
supposed to go out and complete the tasks
and then they report to the captain that
they completed its ass telling that Captain
to find more tasks and so then the captain
creates more tasks right and then that's its
own Loop that keeps them going in a little
circle but then their circles inside the
circles each time they go on a loop cuz this
is how I'm trying I'm trying to structure
the system right and so each time they go on
there in the circle will call it a cycle I'm
sorry that I'm not
Like thinking proper but like you called me
brainstorming right so
And and this is not
None of this is new bro I have like seven
implementations of this exact same project
That all blow up for the same reason
The difference is this time it only blew up
to $2,000And 500 of those were documents.
The last time it blew up to 500,000And all
of those were nested duplications.
So
I have a lot of hope that's not that's a big
that's a big disparity right there like
either I've gotten better the systems gotten
better the AI has gotten better or try a
triangle all of the three all of the above
Got to be option DI'll wait optionally could
have just got lucky.
But we don't take it also couldn't have been
itUnless go still waiting on the last two
let me get my baby.
What have you been working on it what's up
with what's up with your world
Cuz now now I've been kind of screaming just
soI could.
See what the agents do when I sleep like I
plan on the streams will be long so that I'm
pretty much
Able to go back and see what happened I
could record it on my own but you know
switch as a lovely feature plus I'm building
every day regardless so
I just got the agents well while all seven
of the other agents were working I was
working with agents
Not andAgent 6 is.
Good cuz maybe you can help to identify when
they go on a loop and what or why cuz that's
Cuz that's the thing I want to figure out
why they duplicate and I can't well it's not
that I can't I don't have a really good way
of going all the way up and reading
everything you see what I'm saying so I
really
This is one of the first few times that I
really have it on the autonomous and I'm
watching ask them why did they
Why do they keep duplicating
everythingActually.
Well okay let wait I've identified certain
reasons why things get identified I mean get
a duplicated
Okay agents will and that's the thing
creating systems to address these things
because if I could just tell them to stop
duplicating things I would have already done
it
However I did I did just recently add
I did just recently add a format system to
it you can't really see it let's see if I
can open a new file and just show you the
Give me a new text real quickDon't make me
name it. Just give me a new text back.
It's slow right now cuz the other agents you
can't see the other four agents on the other
screen right now but they're going right now
too
But I'm more so interested in these cuz
that's what y'all can see come on new foul
Okay wow
It's just embarrassed meYou're good bro.
Come and go as you please.
Can't see it but this is the format now
it'll tell you what agent goes from what
agent it goes to and then it'll give it a
priority and we need to implement more tax
ThisIs the new thing that we're testing back
from agent.
Cell phone project number one
What happens to my sticky notes being at the
bottom broLet's move them to the bottom what
happens.
Tentative start into the taskbar
Yes yes yes let's add it all the way over
thereStickies whenever we want them.
Pop that out cuz that's what I wanted to
show you was thisIs the new format but.
At the bottom of it right
At the bottom of it I want to add in a
section that tells them toA reminder.
Reminders
Message
Oh shitIt looks like a we got stuff.
That's another thing that seems to stop the
agents too let's let'sLet's let's.
Work on that and then when it comes back I
can also talk about the problem sweet face
Right and soYou are.
AgentLink.
I hope you don't think you'll be playing the
game all dayHell no school started at 10:00.
So if you're not in school book starts.
Or put it on low five musicI like the Lo-Fi
music idea.
Go to YouTube
You need to check to see what you need in
the meantime like it's no way you're on the
game right now and you know you're supposed
to be in school
You tripWhere's the Lo-Fi.
No you're just going to go up there and say
helloFine.
And see you wouldn't have to do all that if
you just did a little bit better read I'll
try and go to do this face and then hit fi
You going to press F and I why would you
need to see it you going to spell it
I'll take pictures of figuredReally.
She said no he said he's saying this he's
staying safe
I will show you the first
But it's okay
I graduated
Graduated
ManTo realize that I said so.
That's what I'm saying I know you smart just
don't tryTo tell you to come wake.
Up
Love I didn't yell at you I meant that with
everything in it I ain't even know it
Know it I almost started cryingPicture.
I knowI'm going to get back to work.
You skip my stuffYou like my music.
You did skip itChris you hella stupid.
But it's getting to my cousin
Grandma
Didn't even give my mouth
That's what you do when you supposed to be
taking a test
That means you're in
What is a 15
Ever since tomorrowAnd then dancing.
I don't think I understand
Though
You're not looking
Yeah
Okay
If they're asking for all of themYou got to
give him.
To themYou can still read.
Something
Mine look like the paper was all that
experience
Don't let me do it for me
I think that would be it
I made the best stuff with youI miss it.
Bye-bye.
Not too sureIs better.
See the difference or not
You see the difference or notI'm starting to
see the difference.
BreakfastOf sustainable.
They don't take the other oneSend out. I
would delete the others before.
Some kind of mistake happensIt's not the
last one.
Hey where you goDid you hear me.
It's the one that I showed you is the one
that keys
I think that's going to take it upside
downYou can flip it upside up.
There it is
Crap
InterestingTell me that doesn't look like
they're looking at the back.
That's what they're asking me to fucking do
Alright now let's get back to this workYeah
yeah.
What have you been trying to message
withThat becomes the real question.
To confirm your answers on your test
Charlie all I ever see you doing in school
is playing your gameYou playing your game
all through school huh.
You like School onlineYou like School
online.
Sunday Sunday
I thought you said that they had to wait
Cuz if they let you send it that might have
not that they needed something else or does
that mean they denied it again
Cuz if they let you send it again that might
have meant that they needed something else
Or did they reject the first one like you
need to know this
Email they said that where does it say that
I'm not asking you what you thinking I'm
asking them I'm asking you what they said
Chris
This ain't even you personal
YesAnd so where did you send the other stuff
to.
Netflix explanation
Do you need me talking about itYou know.
Who.
ER
So it didn't say this at first
It said this
Wrong letterNo no.
Next song
At 12:49A.m..
Siri take my phone off too not too straight
Monster
You can tell her about to catch people you
put your hair finger over exactly when they
sleep
Emergency
True wake up
You are asleep
Bus
50% off
Me
I was looking
JoshOkay.
Oh I'm sorry I thought I was going to hit
him too
Thanks buddy
I had to get up and sayOh nice day.
Okay so I don't even got to press for it no
more to do a square back
Okay all rightOkay.
Post Oak road conditions
Go to the thing where I say session names
it's going to say 6th grade
It is going to say Section 8 minutes
My hello
Assistant everything about $300
And I improved
I'm going to talk
What's up
No I'mma lose my wife
I can't do itWell morning time.
Did you leave
The same thing happens
Can
Yesterday
And my ex's sick whenever I don't want to
ImagineWhatever.
But it's dry
Oh oh yeah did you fart
What is the difference is multitude so I got
to talk
What's up sleep
I wish I would have lost my hands but I made
a little mess in a bad thing
All right let's see what the agents have
been
All right I don't forgive you
Doing for Christmas
Again
We not know if you pass if you pass this
great Dale send them all the way up to 8:30
Or complete in high school a year early
So he could do like 17 6th grade right now I
was talking about those seventh grade
classes where you being statistics and I
mean in geometry in Spanish
But that means you got to be in pre-ap
classes and stuffThey're not going to care
if you got held back in 6th grade.
When you get to 12th grade
But this is your sign I need to step it up
Cuz now when you plan you ain't even you
ain't even holding back people in your
generation you don't have yourself back
So every distraction in class you making is
youHolding everybody back.
But don't worry about it cuz that's not what
we going to be on we going to be on the
other side of it where we going to try and
make up for what we doneRight.
And that start with you studying for that
test that Charlie got in about what what
time try to get what time do you got this
shift Charlie what's on the study cuz you
need to be with him right now like that's
what you need to be on brother you going to
be in his class
Not in his class but you going to have a
classThat study in the same stuff.
They wouldn't disrespect you by putting you
on the same class I hope not
I don't know I never had a class materialBut
I did have a class with k.
But they took me out of that class so fast
it was fucking fast it was fucking funny
They did not want me in the same class with
my boy they knew who was going to be a
problem
Yeah yeah soon as she found out just like no
no no switching that immediatelyAnd I
understand too cuz I just got kicked out of
car.
And appointed me coming over to LCHolding my
boys back.
That's why I say I'm not making fun of you
we in the same boat Chris
That's why it's hard to hurt cuz I know how
you feel right now like I felt like this
And it was even worse cuz I had to go up to
the school they didn't have online school
So I just watch the people that graduated
without me on Facebook graduating going to
prom and all that and I'm still in school
And that shit hurtMade me care even less I
ain't going to lie that was me.
I don't think they're ever going to stop
Mama how are you
School
You don't know y'all be saying you your new
me did you get it did you text your teacher
until that's your name wasn't popular
Bro
Yep
Nope
What okay so much for all World Cup
You get a name
Just kidding we got McDonald's
Money
Georgina okay no
Do you want a pet or notBut I bet.
Question mark
Period I'm good
This is so hardNo it's listening.
My name
Wake up boy
AsleepBoy. Maybe you drive Christine yet.
If
Hop
Okay so it looks like the loop is breakingNo
never mind.
Myself
I'm trying to risk it for myself
Oh man
See that charges the same like this one but
this is way better
This charger is better than that than your
black one even though it's not inside of
here they did it like that it's way better
Is there water in the fridge
Check it she texted you back cuz they don't
take long to text back to school
What's your question uglyStop lying Charlie.
Charlie I'm not going home look in the
mirrorTell me you see something pretty.
LiveThat's right that's the most handsome
man looking in the mirror right now.
Until I started looking
I'm just messing with your man
The small man in my big jacketFor now.
Your Roosters on usOkay.
Siri
No no no what's up with foot
IMy boyfriend.
IsHey.
Hey you're not goingBye. Bye.
Oh I'm a little window
You doneAre you okay you supposed to be
working on something you bothering him.
I ain't bothering him you are
That's awesome
It works
Joshua facial all right
Or something
No
ArmyLooking door.
Hello hello
Taco Bell I have ice cream and my brother
was still get it
Taco get it perfect
I special with medium before strawI'm going
to get you back.
Okay
Business of bothering me you love me
thoughYou're welcome.
So what it's uncomfortable but it's hard to
explain how much
Like
Self defense empty turn on now worried about
the wrong thing Chris
I'll change my passwordI'm going to put you
in Spanish my password is easier.
It's easiest to unlock
Phone
Christmas record
Escape
We don't quit no more now we chill and die I
will cry watch your brothers falling back to
pray you never know that pain
Damn I give it a couplePhone.
If you open today I want you to come over
here
I'm
Here are too close
If you want
In this number
Face and send with his face
And she's the only one that
I know that's going to happen
I mean I got the screen running I got the
Webcam filter running they just can't see me
right now but that's only cuz I sent the
video off it's not that it's not processing
the video please for instance if I wanted to
show me right now I could just do the puy
the TV the actual little thing for the
previous you see I put a preview in there
now yeah that's what it look like
But I'm also like in the background I want
to put on switch
On the PSISo we can see when you're done on
the building.
That way I don't have to have that screen
upAnd it'll be that baby Spring right there.
See that really sucks that this agents not
working the agent too
Because agent number two
Has the best format for working and I
deleted it
So it's going to be hard for me to replicate
it unless I scroll to the top
Luckily the systems finally stopped soHere
we go.
It's still up
Like
Despicable
Vacancy
Right now that's just this I don't have it
upBut if it was over here.
ButI can also like.
I just have it off
I got to walk around
Talking decision circus
?
Me
She didn't
Worcester Avenue
I don't feel like dinner with me I don't
feel like hearing that shit that
I'm only here for the money I won't last
night so I'm hoping that it's going back
here
Where it might more remember will cause it
to go backI may lose it.
By doing5 to win this which is the scary
part. But. Yellow.
Only it's not responding
The problem
Can you buy me some pictures
Oh God
And before I went back I should have grabbed
the cities there are 20 to do that won't get
done
Them
Today
Okay it's going to work
Yeah
Wait wait wait
What happens when I singThe agent. A
screenshot.
Open YouTube I'm sorry
Have him check itWhat's wrong.
Number
Applications
My name is not a gift
Haven't been done 24 hours ago
I'm sorry
I don't really love you
SelfieAnd.
It works
HereSo we can take our test.
This electric thing that got my TV
Wake up
Right
Now
Oh yeah
I lost the philosopher Columbus
Red Bull
My back
Spotify
Nothing
HahaI don't know.
Think of a ball right stop thinking about
Right
Now
What's outside look up above and go for 20
minutes
Right so
Right so get upStart working on.
Jesus
The question
Lego
Funny pictures
Talking
Tom
Still open come on
FacebookSpecial. Special YouTube.
I got them a question
?I almost just killed myself.
I was in Discovery
It's notAwesome.
Thank you so easyTo cancel. Saturday.
Just come in
ChrisCome on now come over here.
Talking
InstrumentalEmergency response.
Tomorrow
Have 50%
?
To see what you know
You
Coffee at 7:00 370 the assignment
Madison
Got the last time and I'll even need it
Chris nutrition
I bet
You
You know
I output so you try to play the system
That's not youThat's not a question.
The biggest so hard to
No but I'm goodOh you did this.
You can do it
Yep
Washington Washington no no no
I'm walking song
I couldn't hear youCan I get the red
controller.
Can I get the red controllerOn playground.
Yes yes yesPartner.
I wasn't upset with my flight I was upset
with my controller
We wonBut that controller is like.
I don't want to cheat like that controller
it thank you that controller
Like broke I got to go give me a performance
control over people
And then it started sticking
So we're going to get started
Yet
In the boxing job went onYou.
I wouldn't even write thoseAre you even
worried about that and you know.
See
Duffy's talking about Grandpa
How did they make moreThan me.
I knowMe a bunch.
In between my break but all the humans are
wiped off when they're all asteroid hit the
Earth
You know how did they surviveCase. I didn't
take and that was in the bank.
So I would say diamond shoes they ain't
going to change it to you
It's a dinosaur in real life
For free you got the bugs throwing you are
you and two brothers all videos
Call Captain the 1999 let them look like a
Because you didn't know anything
1903That's why.
Size in my pants
Whenever once everything I said
He thought it was replaced
Replica of me
Book what to do the test not me
Read it
Fine
Well my feelingsDown.
Definitely I said new soonHe wouldn't come
over.
Get off your phone
Character my job
This is my dad
That's it my dadSo call me back.
So you just answerI don't think so.
Things to
No sorry she'll bring me dinner with a good
picture family
NoBecause you can't you don't know to answer
your TV tomorrow.
Lottery 4 minutes
Said that everythingThey all get.
It's fun like I said it's true
Question mark
I have one
I know that's in the Bluetooth
Booty
NoWe're going to do that cold.
Do you remember to come
No stop playing go to the thingWe got to go
to the video that I found.
It
I'm going to go check it
But what you really think about it
Again
Cake status
The
The comments make it easy
Did you read it to me I can hold it
No
Are youIf we play if you want which I ain't
text.
Cool
Talk
It worksBoth y'all about to be kicked off
the game all day.
Cuz y'all doing too much y'all playing right
now so you don't need to play later
It's okay keep rocking the chair keep
playing keep doing everything you're
doingLike I said.
I'm not doing nothing either and you won't
be doing nothing later
That's what I'm saying let me do it that way
you could just say it I'll be faster
I want nothingYeah.
It has to be number oneI could just be
number one real quick.
Nevermind
Don't work so delete that8:00. YH.
Trailer
K e sDash.
1 s r n
OpeAnd.
71Envy. G1.
M6NS.
Send it
And name
16P 8. W f.
3TIt don't work.
That's the brand one
Word
I got the last oneNo you should have been
paying attention.
Now
You could have figured this out while
reading
Never let Josh do this
Are you at that stripe miles Brown again
Optimus okay this is your dishes Yoda in
your name I don't care
Cuz honestlyThe. It's. My love.
If you do kqzn
B
Good luckYou got to ask you know.
You did you even know what it is
NoIt's all about it. Are you still in the
same address the last time.
Bro it seems free
Lucky person it's either it's no longer I
MaybeYeah I know.
Woman needed not it I send them
Phone
Oh she don't got no defense
Hard to Guess Who
No no it's pretty much start and
Stuff
Can't see as well can't walk in is Good from
back here
Until you get good and figure out who you
really want when you really want
Large enough to catch a big faceNo because.
I couldn't detective fish.
For the first one disrespect me
Ena
How to make my bedDoing a test.
What to be making
A child
Well he asked what
Talking to myself asleep again